>> BRUCE: Now, I want to show and tell you
about another--actually, I want to introduce
Jason to tell you about another real world
example of a CodeSplitting success story,
the next slide Jason Bright from MediaBeacon.
Jason.
>> BRIGHT: Thanks.
>> BRUCE: Please.
>> BRIGHT: So, I'm Jason Bright. I'm the founder
of MediaBeacon, and we're an enterprise digital
asset management company. And we provide enterprise
asset management to customers, which in general
at more than 100 employees and have millions
of files to distribute among those employees.
And we decided to go with GWT as our interface
technology for many reasons. And I could talk
about it for awhile, but I think it's easier
to show it. So, if we jump to the MediaBeacon
server, we can log on and you see that it's
a widget based interface that has, literally,
hundreds of widgets which are available. And
you can place all the widgets on the pages
and then you can share this workspace with
different users. And we can do some really
magical things with GWT, so I can do things
like drag and drop, and I can hover and expand
folders, and there is no flash on this page.
So, this allows you to do all the highly interactive
things that you expect of the desktop in a
simple web interface and then search your--and
MediaBeacon is unique because it has strongly
attached metadata that's written in to the
assets. So as the assets move, you know everything
about them. Now, one of the things that we
did is we put all these highly interactive
widgets that have to be able to drag and drop
and send message to each other. You'll see
when I click on one, it updates the rest.
So, we're doing a lot of GWT magic between
these individual widgets. And when I want
to configure the interface, I literally have
hundreds and hundreds of widgets to select
from. In addition to that, we use Open Syndication
and OpenSocial to get an even larger set.
So, let me grab one from OpenSocial, and I'll
go on iGoogle for a second. Grab an iGoogle
Widget. I use Google Docs a lot, so I'll just
grab my gadget. I'll go click a link. Grab
the URL, copy it. And then, go ahead and go
into my Syndication Widget, and I'm going
to paste it right in there. And as soon as
it comes up, I can tell that it's not supposed
to have as much size as it thinks it wants.
So, I can--my hand won't stop shaking. I guess
I am nervous. And I can say how large it supposed
to be, and then I can save. Now, I'm happy
with that and I can bring that to a point
of prominence, up here. And then, I can take
my date search widget over there and I can
name it, My Docs, great. So now, I have an
interface that has both OpenSocial Widgets
and highly connected widgets. And now, here's
the problem. The problem was that this codebase
kept getting bigger and bigger, because GWT
let us go farther and farther and be more
and more aggressive with what we can develop.
And so, if we go back to my slides, the problem
was we got up to 1.5meg before you saw the
lagging screen. Because everything that had
to be highly interactive and had to allow
drag and drop and events pass in between each
other, it had to be part of that initial download.
So it got incredibly painful, and before you
could see the lagging screen, most people
click away. And so, if--when we put CodeSplitting
in, we were able to jump from this 1.5meg
to 109k compress. So, that's smaller than
the logo next to the login window is. And
we're not making the logo smaller, just so
you know. All right. And so, the great part
is as I was able to gain all of this improvement
and what's great is that I didn't have to
work very hard for it, relatively speaking.
So, if you look at the next slide, you'll
see that we had at about 16 lines of code,
because our application is all based on widgets,
since the widgets know when to load. The widgets
are a part of context when you switch from
context to context. So, we simply ran--added
a bunch of runAsyncs and we're able to gain
1.4meg per 16 lines of code, which is a pretty
great savings. So, in summary, MediaBeacon
is a real world application. It had a very
large number of functions that had to be interrelated.
The widgets weren't on the screen at the same
time. This is a real world example were CodeSplitting
allowed us deliver the functionality that
we need without having the users have an unfortunate
experience, and now they think it's really,
really perky. So, we're very proud of the
CodeSplitting and we're very happy, the fact,
that we didn't have to do much for it. And
we think that this--that we chose GWT out
of all the other industry standards and we
think that GWT, it has really, in an instant,
made us an industry leader ahead of all the
other products, because of the Toolkit we
used. So, thank you. Thanks very much, Bruce.
Thank you.
[END]